you're in the great game now and the
great game is terrifying
when you play the game of Thrones you
win you die
there is no middle ground
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
8 Q&A video before I get started I just
want to thank Chris stable field for
helping me out with that intro for my
videos Chris actually reached out to me
on his own without me even asking and he
offered to make me an intro for free
which we all know I've needed for quite
some time so I just wanted to take a
moment and thank him for doing that
because I know it had to have taken
several hours to make if all of you
don't mind show Chris some love down in
the comments section please now what I
want to do today is answer a few more
questions some of you left me the other
day so without further ado let's begin
the first question is from Jamie and she
says I was thinking about your last
video and the theories about what the
Night Kings motives could be what are
your personal thoughts about why the
night king spared the few lives that he
did I think it might be tied to the
spread of information it seemed the only
reason the first guy of the Nights Watch
that Ned executed was spared to spread
the word that the White Walkers had
returned
perhaps they also spared Sam to do the
same thing perhaps they knew of Sam's
ambitions for the Citadel the place
where histories and the truth is
ultimately located if this is true what
would be the reason why the night king
wants others to know he is coming one
would think he wants to keep some
element of surprise although my mind
could not think of any other reason why
the night king would spare those lives
also not many people even believe those
that had lived to tell the tale so
perhaps the night King knew that as well
these are excellent questions Jamie I
know I have wondered many of these same
things as well and I'm sure there are
some people listening that are curious
about this too so I will do my best with
giving my opinion on these topics okay
so why did the White Walkers allow the
man from the Nights Watch to live in
season 1 episode 1 and why did the white
Walker allow Samwell Tarly to live in
season 2 episode 10 since the night king
is most likely controlling or commanding
all of the soldiers in his army they
must have let them live because the
night King wanted them to be spared for
some specific reason the easy answer is
the night king one of them to live too
fear and warned people to stay out of
the north now I know some people believe
the white Walker didn't even see Sam but
that is not true
the white Walker looked directly at Sam
and he chose to leave him be if you
watch the clip you can see Sam look down
at the horse's hooves as it gets beside
him then he looks up at him then the
white Walker looks down right where Sam
was sitting there is no way the white
Walker wouldn't have known Sam was there
because the others can actually smell
hot blood inside of people old nan said
this in her tale about the last hero he
went looking for the children of the
forest and he wasn't sure if he would
ever find their secret cities one by one
his friends died and his horse and
finally even his dog and his sword froze
so hard the blade snapped when he tried
to use it and the other smelled the hot
blood in him and came silent on his
trail
stalking him with packs of pale white
spiders big as hounds the white Walker
was too close to not notice in smell Sam
there and the scene ends with the entire
force marching past the rock so why did
they allow Sam to live perhaps Sam
wasn't seen as a threat
Sam was by himself and he was unarmed
according to george RR martin he has
said many times that he doesn't want to
create any characters that were purely
evil or perfectly innocent the others
aren't supposed to be mindless killing
machines they are very intelligent and
strategic with the way that they operate
you would think if their goal was to
kill every single human then they should
have slaughtered all of the wildlings in
their sleep a very long time ago it has
to be something else that is just now
driving them to and through the wall
sure they have killed people in the past
but things are different now something
has caused them to move in force instead
of just small teams of white walkers
they seem to be very organized for the
most part and the logical reason for
them allowing Sam to live would be for
him to spread the news that winter is
truly coming for Westeros as of right
now the White Walkers seemed to be evil
creatures because we have seen them
during entire villages then they even
arranged the mutilated body parts into
weird symbols that must have some
meaning behind them we are led to
believe that they are evil but we have
yet to see the twist
at the end of this story we have only
been looking at the means and not the
motive and this leads me to your next
point in your question you said maybe
the night king wanted Sam to live
because he knew about Sam's ambitions of
becoming a Meister now this is a very
interesting point for a few different
reasons Sam might actually be the man
who finds out exactly what the night
king wants or what is causing him to do
what they have been doing Sam may find
an answer that ends up making the night
King look like a sympathetic character
which this story tends to do just take a
look at Jamie Lannister for instance
everyone hated Jaime in season one but
now a vast majority of those same people
feel bad for Jaime now and the same
thing could happen with the night king
once we begin to understand his motives
right before Sam left the Citadel he
took several books with him because he
knows those are the books that will help
him find the answers we have all been
looking for so perhaps the night King
did know Sam would be the man to do this
so he allowed him to live in order to
fulfill his destiny the night king may
want this information out there so
people understand what he wants or to
remind people of the pact that had been
made several thousands of years ago now
in order for this to be true that would
mean the night King would have to have
some sort of green site like Bloodraven
or bran stark how else would the night
King know Sam would eventually go to the
Citadel and take all these books about
the others in the long night well I
think there is some evidence that points
to the night King using the weirwood
system just like bran and the children
of the forest do as we all know the
children were the ones that created the
night king in the first place so perhaps
he acquired some of their powers when
they did this we have seen the night
King physically interact with brain
stark inside of the weirwood net and I
think he knew bran was going to be there
so he set him up so he could touch him
and gain access to the three-eyed Ravens
cave it also seemed as if the night King
set up the Narus to lose at least
one of her dragons the night King
allowed John to sit on that rock all
night as he watched from a distance
while him and several other White
Walkers were holding ice Spears we all
know how accurate the night king is with
those Spears so why didn't he throw
those at John until he killed him the
night King had to have had known
Daenerys was coming so he patiently
waited until he had his chance to take
out her dragons these are just a few
small things that make me think the
night king can also see different events
like brain does but does this mean the
night king actually allowed same to live
because he knew Sam would ultimately
help him in some way I think this is a
very cool idea but I don't think it's
actually true I want to play a video
clip for you that might help answer this
question there is some DVD commentary to
this episode when Samwell Tarly
sees the White Walkers for the first
time the director of this episode
actually reveals a few small things
about this scene director Alan Taylor
and Emilia Clarke gave their commentary
for this episode and this is what they
had to say during the scene what the
hell is that
dry-ice stuff come in smoke coming off
can he see him yes he's looking at
they're looking right at each other
[Music]
something I always liked about the scene
was that you think okay it's curtains
for you and in fact is the John's
John is trivial John doesn't matter as
you can see the person who actually
directed this episode said salmon the
white Walker were looking directly at
each other which does seem pretty
obvious to me but I know some people
didn't believe that at first the funny
thing is the director accidentally kept
calling Sam by John's name in that clip
he meant to say Sam but he said John
didn't matter and John was trivial to
the white walkers at that point which is
why they didn't kill him
at the end of the day I think they just
did that scene for stylistic purposes
they shot it that way because it looked
cool and they wanted us to see the army
of the Dead through the eyes of a POV
character if the night King truly let
Sam live for some reason then what he
did next doesn't make much sense because
in the very next episode one of the
whites tried to kill Sam so I don't
think they allowed him to live for some
bigger purpose the white came after Sam
and attempted to kill him the reason why
the white Walker let him go was because
it looked really cool in that scene and
they couldn't afford to lose Sam at that
moment because he still had a big role
to play in later seasons I would love
for this scene to have a deeper meaning
to it but since the night king tried to
kill Sam in the very next episode I
don't think there is any real
significance to it but that's just my
opinion this next question is from Finn
James although I don't think it will
happen imagine for a second that the
night King does win the Great War and
conquer King's Landing what do you think
his next move would be would he invade
Essos and conquer the rest of the game
of throne own world to consolidate power
invade the Iron Islands also if he did
win would anyone try to retake Westeros
from abroad this is a really good
question and it's kind of hard to answer
because we really don't know how far the
others went during the first long night
this all depends on what the night King
actually wants if the night king wants
to wipe out the human race then I would
say yes the night king will go to the
end of the map in order to kill everyone
but if the night King has a specific
target in mind like something in
Westeros then he would really have no
reason to go to Essos
there is a little evidence that may
suggest the others were in Essos before
because the legend of azor Ahai comes
from Essos as well as were lore that's
all Melisandre talks about is the
darkness that is coming to lay over the
world so if they are talking about this
in Essos and azor Ahai comes from Essos
then perhaps the others didn't make it
that far during the first long night the
main question is how would the others
cross the sea to get to Essos the night
king has a dragon so he could
technically fly over there but his army
would be stuck unless they all boarded
ships or somehow froze the entire sea
now that the wall was down the other's
magic is no longer contained in the far
north so maybe they have the ability to
freeze the sea now or once darkness
falls over Westeros the seas may begin
to freeze on their own there is a quote
from the books that says the seas have
frozen solid before if that would happen
they could walk over there there is a
location in Essos known as the five
forts and they are side-by-side which
basically makes a barrier preventing
someone or something from getting in or
out many people believe these five forts
were built in Essos to protect them from
something from a very long time ago
there is also tales in the world of Ice
and Fire book and these tales come from
beyond the Free Cities it says they tell
of pale blue mists that move across the
water mists so cold that any ship they
pass over is frozen instantly they also
tell of drowned spirits who rise at
night to drag the living down into the
Great Green deaths of all the queer and
fabulous denizens of the Shivering sea
however the greatest are the ice dragons
these colossal beasts many times larger
than the Dragons of Valyria are said to
be made of living ice with eyes of pale
blue crystal and vast translucent wings
through which the moon and stars can be
glimpsed as they will across the sky
whereas common dragons breathe flame ice
dragons supposedly breathe cold a chill
so terrible that it can freeze a man
solid in
half a heartbeat if you believe most of
the legends then it appears as if the
others conquered most of the known world
in the world of Ice and Fire book there
is also a section about the long night
and it says that is also written that
there are annals in a shy of such a
darkness and of a hero who fought
against it with a red sword his deeds
are said to have been performed before
the rise of Illyria in the earliest age
when old geese was first forming its
empire this legend has spread west from
a shy and the followers of real or
claimed that this hero was named as aura
high if this legend is true then the
others most likely made it to Essos
which would mean they probably wiped out
most of Westeros however now that the
others have returned I do not believe
their goal is to make it to Essos I
highly doubt they are on a mission just
to wipe out humanity I believe they have
a target in Westeros and when and if
they reach this target that's where the
story will end many people believe the
night King is heading for the gods i
while I tend to believe he's going to
Winterfell because of his stark
connections but either way both of those
locations are in Westeros and I don't
believe he will get any further than
that if the night King planned on
killing every single human then I would
say yeah he will go to the end of the
world but that doesn't seem to be his
only objective he does have a motive and
reasoning for the things he does but
these are just my opinions I want to
answer one more quick question then I
will get out of here I wanted to address
this in my last video but I wanted to
keep it short but now is a good time to
answer this
James Barlow says Dana watched your last
video and the first question you
answered was about the possible end of
House Stark if John is the one who keeps
House Stark going then what happens to
House Targaryen as far as I know Danny
is the last Targaryen the child that
they have together
assuming they get married before the
baby is born would be legitimately a
Targaryen if John chose to have the baby
named Stark it would end House Targaryen
if he chose the name Targaryen then
House Stark ends
there's a bit of a conundrum yes I would
understand why you would think that and
many other people made this same point
in that video I made so let me address
this situation when I said John would
save House Stark that was under the
assumption that Arya Sansa and bran
would not have any kids because the
person who asked me the question said
how will the Starks save their house
considering none of the Starks are
sexually active right now
which in that case it really only leaves
John because he just had sex with
Daenerys and she's likely pregnant
Sansa Arya or Bryan would have to enter
a relationship and have a kid pretty
quickly considering there is only six
episodes left but since John already had
sex he seems like the best choice in
terms of who will have a child before
the series ends I think there is a very
good chance Daenerys could have twins if
Danny gives birth to two kids they could
give one child the stark name and the
other child the Targaryen name you could
essentially kill two birds with one
stone
even if Daenerys doesn't have twins her
and John could always have more children
later as soon as John finds out she's
pregnant he's gonna want to marry her
because he doesn't want to father a
bastard
as long as neither of these characters
die I think they will continue what
their relationship which means they
could have several children and give
them whatever name they please now if
Sansa Arya or even brain had a kid then
they could save their house on their own
and John wouldn't be needed for that at
all but until that happens John seems
like the man for the job
since the bail the bards story has so
many parallels to John's own birth it
feels like John would be the one to
repeat history from that story by being
the bastard who saves House Stark I
should have clarified that in the video
but I didn't want to ramble too long so
I didn't mention the fact that I believe
Daenerys could have several kids and
potentially save two major houses by
doing so that's what I really meant by
that so hopefully that answers your
question anyways I want to thank
everyone for watching today's video I
really appreciate that I also want to
thank all of my patreon supporters
all of you have given me a tremendous
amount of help during the off season and
I cannot thank you enough for that I
hope everyone has a great day and I will
see you in the next video bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]